hey how about that you know you have 17
amas to your name but something tells me
this is the one huh this is the
centerpiece yes you know there's always
that I mean don't get me wrong 17 is
pretty good but the centerpiece
which means I lived to receive it
exactly I mean it's kind of amazing to
see your name and then icon Right Above
It where's this guy going dead center in
the middle of my Den in my I've got a
little Office Den that has the lock and
key of my lock and key the problem that
I'm having here is check the fine print
on the back I defy you if you can read
that because we're selling over 125
million albums did you even know that
statement one more time in that case
I'll be back how does it feel I mean
especially to get all that love out
there
surreal
because like I said I started here I
started here as the kid in the in the
audience going okay
do I get this award the answer is no and
do you get this award no and you get
this award no and then one day they said
yes
and yes and then you want to come back
some more
and then I got a call from the Clark and
he said do you want to host the show
come on another whole era so how about
this so now when you see your fellow
American Idol judges do they have to
refer to you as icon now
don't get Luke and Katie can I tell you
they just call me Lionel I'm happy
because any other words that come out
I'm a little suspicious okay I got to
tell you you're braving the elements
tonight because not only does this award
look sharp but MGK's suit you were
sitting right next to those spikes but
listen let me tell you something and the
first thing I did was how pointed are
they he said noise soft okay and I'm and
I tested it out okay it's good it looks
it looks abrasive it looks like it's
gonna hurt but it doesn't it looks like
a hazard but Lionel survive John you're
good no he's a very talented very
talented and tonight I think he got some
people back but for whatever he was mad
about he got him back
[Music]
foreign